breaking only moments ago from the New
York Times major new development and
John Durham's investigation into the
origins of the Russia probe this is huge
by the way if your name is Brennan
clapper or Comey you may want to lawyer
up because Durham is now seeking
interviews especially with top CIA
officers that's right investigation into
the investigators is going to be
all-encompassing like we've been telling
you will likely now spread across
continents pay attention to Italy Great
Britain and Australia according to the
time CIA director Gina Haskell rightly
is instructing her agency to fully
cooperate and they will from the dirty
dossier to the rampant spying against
Trump associates and then the leaking of
sensitive material to rig an election
the single biggest abuse of power
scandal in American history the truth is
now being covered the boomerang of all
boomerangs of Justice is in full swing
and high-ranking former bureaucrats they
are in deep deep trouble tonight and
there's no stopping this train and
meanwhile Democrats and of course their
friends and the media mob they are still
fixated on one issue and one only rage
psychosis against the President as we
speak once again apoplectic this is
actually the most amazing setup you'll
ever see brand new interview clip
between the president and ABC's George
Stephanopoulos the resident Clinton
sycophant take a look your campaign this
time around if foreigners if Russia if
China if someone else offers you
information an opponent should they
accept it or should they call the FBI
I think maybe you do both I think you
might want to listen I don't there's
nothing wrong with listening if somebody
called from a country Norway we have
information on your opponent oh I think
I'd want to hear it you want that kind
of interference in our elections it's
not an interference they have
information I think I'd take it if I
thought there was something wrong I go
maybe to the FBI now this is what's
fascinating let's be very clear you
might want to listen listening is much
different than let's see lying spying
and paying for Russian lies and
spreading it through the media by deep
state operatives and then using it as
the base of a FISA warrant because
Hillary Clinton if the media is outraged
over you might want to listen and then
report it to the FBI why are they not so
outraged about Hillary paying for
Russian lies this information call me
generously using the unverifiable data
from Russia to spy on the Trump campaign
and get a FISA warrant no doubt by the
way this will all get another round of
fake phony moral selective outrage over
that interview but it's the perfect
setup because if they're outraged about
that and how can you not be outraged
over what I just said of course that's
all to be expected many ways that was
actually a genius set up because the
media mom
will fall right into his trap recklessly
spewing fake phony outrage over a
non-story for days we'll be showing you
the tape this time tomorrow night
ignoring the real abuse of power that
took place in 2016 and the real Russian
dossier that was bought and paid for and
then used as a basis to spy on the Trump
campaign more proof if you needed it the
media mob is nothing more than an
extension of the Democratic Party
oh they're worried about let's see
obstruction of justice but only if it's
Trump not Hillary they're worried about
underlying crimes but only if it's Trump
on Hillary they're worried about
believing but only if it bludgeons Trump
not the attorney the lieutenant governor
of the state of Virginia the
Commonwealth of Virginia over serious
sex allegations so all of this comes as
top Democrats have their heads I won't
say it the way I want to in the sand
today
they turn Capitol Hill into the twilight
zone no liar
the Cowardly Adam Schiff come on the
show Schiff come please for hours for
you free he held yet another hearing
about his favorite fantasy the Russian
hoax the only guy that's caught on tape
colluding with Russians and Schiff knows
there was zero Trump Russia collusion
for previous investigations all
concluding collusion is a lie in a myth
and improvable but that doesn't matter
to the Cowardly Adam shift because he's
nothing more than a liar and a con
artist that's why he won't come on this
show his sole mission is to smear
President Trump every second hour of
every day just like the mob and the
media that's why the house Intel
committee chair held yet another sham
hearing today on what he called
disturbing findings of volume one of the
Muller report read it don't forget the
same volume that totally cleared Trump
in his entire campaign it said quote the
investigation did not establish mr.
Schiff what part of this don't you
understand that members of the Trump
campaign conspired or coordinated with
the Russian government in its election
interference activities only one on a
phone call with Russia looking for
disinformation is you in a hoax the only
one that paid for Russian Liza's your
candidate Hillary six hundred and
seventy five days twenty eight hundred
subpoenas five hundred search warrants
five hundred witnesses two hundred
thirty orders for communication records
nineteen hyper-partisan anti-trump
investigators and all democratic donors
even hillary clinton's attorney the
worst attorney Andrew Weissman on the
face of the earth over 25 million
dollars spent and even Muller's team
found no collusion instead they were
only able to produce a four hundred and
some-odd page document filled with
smears insinuation and even took an
edited tape of the Trump Attorney Dowd
out of context a heavily edited
voicemail to make attorney John Dowd
look bad Wow a total mischaracterization
of mana Ford's business associate the
Muller report totally admitted Fusion
GPS they were complicit in paying for
the Russian lies and propaganda they
hired steel on behalf of Clinton and
that's only the tip of the ice
berg that they missed and how could they
not investigate the phony Russian
dossier if you're investigating Russia
interference in 2016 so today's bogus
hearing congressman Devin Nunez probably
delivered the best speech of his career
he'll join us in a minute
watch this eventually the democrats
became convinced that the molar report
would finally rid them of their sinister
president who had the audacity to defeat
Hillary Clinton the Democrats assembled
us today to analyze the shoddy political
hit piece known as the molar report it's
written in the same spirit and with the
same purpose as the steel dossier which
was once championed by Democrats on this
committee but which they rarely
mentioned after it was exposed as yet
another Democrat created hoax
unfortunately for the Democrats the
molar dossier as I call it either
debunked many of their favorite
conspiracy theories or did not even find
them worth discussing
coming up congressman Nunez will expand
more on what he is calling the Muller
dossier I wish I thought of that and
it's likely author devout trumpeter
Andrew Weissman now he's the career
prosecutor Andrew Weissman that is the
pit bull as labeled by the New York
Times of Muller actually attended the
2016 election night victory party for
Hillary he's also a partisan Democratic
donor his track record horrific Sidney
Powell's book license to lie just as a
brutal takedown detailing Weissman in
his notorious withholding of exculpatory
information and prosecutorial misconduct
in one case remember he sent for Merrill
executives to prison for a year that
verdict overturned by the Fifth Circuit
it was yet another case he got
overturned nine zero what an achievement
by the Supreme Court
thousands of Anderson accounting
employees they lost their jobs because
of Weissman and tonight we can report
that Weissman's biggest critic Sydney
Powell
thank goodness has now been hired to
represent Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn that's the legal team responsible
for Flynn's guilty plea has been sacked
Powell who has said 16 months ago
blasting the mall of witch-hunt is now
taking over now no word if he plans to
withdraw but a change of course certain
looks imminent Powell's said 16 months
ago he should withdraw that plea I agree
especially in light of what the
government did to a 33 year retired
general a war hero who served this
country with honor and distinction what
they did is graceful
remember Flynn was illegally amassed
they leaked raw intelligence on him
spied on by high-ranking US government
officials in 2016 and remember after
Trump was sworn in day four of his
administration Comey sent agents to the
White House to set a perjury trap for
Flynn they had already listened to the
tape after the Deputy FBI director and
room it keeps it no no no Flynn you
don't need a lawyer and call me brags
about setting up a 33-year veteran this
is a national disgrace this right here
you look at this White House now and
it's hard to imagine two FBI agents
ending up in the same room how did that
happen I sent them something we probably
wouldn't have done or maybe gotten away
with in a more organized investigation a
more organized administration in the
George W Bush administration for example
or the Obama administration and in both
of those administrations that was
process and so if the FBI wanted to send
agents into the White House itself to
interview a senior official you would
work through the White House Counsel and
there'll be discussions and approvals
and who would be there and I thought
it's early enough let's just send a
couple guys over laughing about taking
advantage of a war hero really James
Comey you're a disgrace you're not the
super Patriot you claim to be you just
seem to be in nothing but a corrupt
career bureaucrat you think you're
untouchable sadly you're what Joe does
Jennifer described I don't want to say
it because it makes me mad knowing most
of my family served in law enforcement
but I have news for the ever so pious
king of the deep state mr. Comey
justices coming your way and I predict
tonight you are going to be held
responsible for committing your fraud
your premeditated fraud on a FISA Court
and that setup you're bragging about of
general Flynn will be your legacy
leaking sensitive government in
information that too will be your legacy
and maybe more if not it certainly
should be